today we're going to show you a level
called the sea like all the environments
in unravel it's based on northern Sweden
our home it's inspired by happy sunny
memories of going to the coast both as a
child as a parent
unravel is a game about reaching out
about mending broken bonds dharni has to
make it to the end of the game without
running out of yarn you can find more
yarn in the levels like this little ball
here and you see to get further
sometimes that extra yarn can be hidden
or hard to reach without yarn you can't
move on so you have to think about how
you use it here you can tie two knots to
create a bridge which also doubles up as
a slingshot you have to be careful
though so you're on doesn't get washed
away you need something to protect yarny
from the waves and that boat fender
floats so you can use it as a raft and
stay safe
but it's got more uses too because it's
so buoyant
the gameplay is all physics-based it's
got a few touches of magic but it's
rounded in realism what you do and how
you tackle problems is really up to you
and your creativity when things get more
difficult you'll have to think of
different ways to combine your knees
abilities or use things in the
environment to find a way forward this
looks like a dead end that's way too
high to jump it's a good thing you can
use your yarn to climb out okay let's
think this through and try another
approach your knee needs that raft again
but getting it over to the other side is
going to be a little bit tricky you're
gonna have to build a couple of yarn
bridges
see those yarn bridges they can carry
objects too so you can make one to get
the fender out of the water
and when you've done that you can build
another bridge and use that to move the
fender over the wooden post
and now you can push your will raft in
place and you can cross the water safety
or fairly safe anyway
as you can see the gameplay is about
overcoming obstacles by using yarn and
the environment to find the path forward
there are many other kinds of moments
beyond the obstacles moments a
reflection of wonder beauty and
discovery with unravel we want to
capture your imagination and test your
cleverness and touch your heart